[Music]
donnie is with us in fayetteville north
carolina hi donnie welcome to the ramsay
show
man it's an honor to talk to you you too
sir what's up
dave i'm in a pickle
all right
uh
i'm 53 years old
have absolutely nothing for retirement
i'm 50 000 in debt
and i want a divorce
okay
what what's what's
going on with your marriage yeah sounds
like you're in a jar of pickles
what's going on with the marriage
well
it's i guess it's just been building
over the last 10 years um
you know just
i'm an over-the-road truck driver and uh
hardly at home
um
now my wife was handling all the bills
and and all the money and
um for a while man we were doing great
right covet hit
uh i was at home
and
we got debt free paid off everything we
had so you're saying you all got along
better when you weren't there
oh yeah we definitely get a lot better
one on my home oh yeah
that's why i've been married for 32
years
that's that's so not funny but i'm sorry
yeah well it is funny actually
but i mean you know last year i mean i
was in a sweet spot we were in a sweet
spot no debt i had six months living
expenses uh saved up i had money we
didn't have to
you know use credit cards anything she
wanted all she had to do was go buy it
you know we were we were set
and then
all of a sudden she just got a wild hair
up her
upper britches and wanted to move into a
house and
doubled our rent
emptied the savings
and then she got crazy and went and got
all these credit cards and
started putting charges on them
and
a couple of weeks i found out i'm thirty
thousand dollars in debt to the tax
to the irs
for years of taxes that she didn't pay
and i guess i should have been a little
more on top of it but yeah a lot
yeah
you know
so now all of that just hits me and and
you know of course
the marriage has sort of been going
downhill for the last 10 years and
no but it wasn't though when y'all were
on the same page and y'all had
y'all were able to sleep again and you
were able to laugh and do something
together again it wasn't so the last
couple years it's been pretty good right
or did y'all come up with this common
purpose we're going to work really hard
together we're going to get out of debt
we're going to do this we're going to be
set up and it was still failing then it
was still falling apart then i don't buy
it
yeah
yeah the marriage was still falling
apart but we were on the same page as
far as finances go
i had approached her with the snowball
uh program and and and and introduced
her to dave she was reluctant and uh you
know i just sort of
i just sort of put my foot down and said
you know look this this is the way it's
just got to be and and this is what it's
going to look like when we're done
and
she she trusted me and so we started
doing that and we achieved our goal
nope nope you didn't no you didn't you
didn't achieve your y'all's goal you
achieved your goal
true i'll give you that
i'll give you that
and so she got debt free
for you and then you went back on the
road and she's still sitting there and
she went with her nowhere
right
right
yeah you're right
[Music]
and i'm just
you know i mean i've been in full panic
mode ever since i turned 50.
you know let me ask you this let me ask
you this what what is the actual
this is a sad situation i'm sorry donny
um
it's a mess and there's a lot of a lot
of things we could deal with in the mess
a lot of pickles in the jar and um
but what how can we best help you
today
i need to figure out something to do
with these taxes
okay
all right that the taxes not being paid
is a symptom the credit card debt is a
symptom
the debt getting paid off
is a symptom
of behaviors and attitudes and beliefs
that you all are
harboring or not harboring and so
um i'll be happy to tell you what to do
with the irs you need to go to
ramseysolutions.com
click on elp for taxes sit down with one
of our tax pros and they'll help you
negotiate a payment plan with the irs
until you can get them paid off
now
then what at the core of this whole
thing
is that you guys suck at communication
in your marriage beyond belief
yes
and it's partly due to you being on the
road it's partly due to you putting your
foot down
only you
missed
when you put your foot down
um you stomped on her toes and yeah all
you did is stop on her toe you didn't
really do anything and uh it's partly
due to her doing whatever she wants
you you guys so then what you've got to
do is you're going to continue to have
financial problems as long as you are
not communicating and aligned on where
we are going and align doesn't mean
you're demanding or she's demanding a
line means we both look into the future
we see a desired future that we both
agree on and then we both agree on the
steps to get to it
we both have a vote and we both are
going to put our shoulder to the wheel
and we're both going to push that's the
only shot your marriage has otherwise
you are divorced
and then you get to go fix
your money problems
and you know
you said that all those things were a
symptom
and of of the behavior
and i agree with that because i mean i i
follow you man including your behavior
including yourself because you're not
plugged in enough to know that the taxes
weren't being paid that's a behavior
and you'll have a dance of the y'all are
doing the dance of the victims where she
did all this to me and then he's on the
road to left me and then he [ __ ]
about the way i do it and then we're
back y'all are
hey you want to get out of the dance of
the victim walk up and take a knee
and take ownership and say here's what
i've contributed for the last 30 years
and i'm willing to change
that's that's the shot you got right
yeah take ownership of it if you guys
can get in alignment and an agreement
you got a really good shot at
straightening up your money stuff and
your marriage absolutely
but if you're not then you just got to
go decide what you're going to do after
you're divorced
and get after it but get in touch with
one of our tax elps and they'll help you
with the tax mess brother i'm sorry
you're facing this